- [Instructor] So we have
an interesting circuit here.
The goal of this video is to
figure out what is the current
that flows through this six-ohm resistor?
Pause this video, and see
if you can work through it.
So the way that I am going to tackle it
is first simplify the circuit.
Take these two resistors in parallel,
and think about what the
equivalent resistance would be.
And we have seen that before.
One over the equivalent resistance
is going to be equal to one over 6.0 ohms
plus one over 12.0 ohms.
1/6 is the same thing as two over 12.
So 2/12 plus 1/12 is 3/12.
And 3/12, you could view that
as the same thing as one over 4.0 ohms.
And so one over the equivalent resistance
is equal to one over four ohms.
Well, that means that
the equivalent resistance
is four ohms.
And so we can simplify our circuit now,
where we replace these
two resistors in parallel
with one resistor of the
equivalent resistance,
and that is going to be
equal to a four-ohm resistor.
Now the next thing we could
do is we could figure out
what the current is through
this part of the circuit,
which would be the same
thing as the current
right over there.
We could call that i sub one.
And we can just use Ohm's law for that.
We would have i sub one would
be equal to our voltage drop,
which is 24 volts,
24 volts
divided by
the equivalent resistance of
these two resistors in series.
And when you have resistors
in series, you just add 'em up
to figure out the equivalent resistance.
So this would be divided by 2.0 ohms
plus four ohms,
plus 4.0 ohms.
24 divided by two plus four,
or 24 divided by six, is four.
And since we're dealing
with two significant digits,
it'll be 4.0.
And we're talking about current,
so this is 4.0 amps, or 4.0 amperes.
Now how do we use that information
to calculate this current right over here?
We can call that i sub two.
Now one way to think about it is
what is going to be your voltage drop
from this point to this point?
If you know the voltage drop
from that point to that point
and if you know that the
voltage drop from this point
all the way down here is,
then we can figure out what
the voltage drop from here
to here is going to be.
So let's do that.
So the voltage drop across
this first resistor,
remember, your change in voltage
is just equal to your current
times your resistance.
And so this is going to be,
your current is going to be four amperes
times your resistance is two ohms,
times two ohms, which is going
to be equal to 8.0 volts.
And so if the voltage
difference between that point
and that point is 24 volts,
which we know from this voltage source,
but if we drop eight volts
as we go to this point,
well, then the difference
between this point and this point
or this point and this
point right over here,
this has got to be a 16-volt drop.
If our delta V across the
six-ohm resistor is equal to
16 volts,
well, then we can use Ohm's
law again to figure out i two.
I sub two is going to be
equal to our drop in voltage,
so 16 volts, divided by this resistance,
six ohms.
And so what is this going to be equal to?
16 divided by six is 2 4/6 or 2 2/3,
or 2.666666, and if we round
to two significant digits,
you're going to have 2.7 amps.
And so we just figured out
what we wanted to figure out.
This right over here is
2.7 amps, or 2.7 amperes.
But we can keep analyzing it.
For fun, I encourage you to figure out
what that current is now,
the current i sub three.
And use the exact same technique.
And one thing that you should
feel very comfortable of
is that this current that is flowing
through the first resistor,
that four-ampere current,
that current gets split
between i two and i three.
And so i two and i three should add up
to the original four amps.
So just thinking about it that way,
if you do the same type
of analysis we just did,
you should get 1.3 amps
for i three because 2.7
plus 1.3 is going to
be equal to four amps.